question carefully away anchor lifted
and underway at last in the darkness
heading east into the Mediterranean a
few hours before the departure supplies
have been loaded on the Adrian Darya one
in the choppy waters a specialist
engineer had been winched up along with
at least five new crew members the
engineer was brought on board to attend
to a technical issue planning to return
to shore
later nightfall and the swell of a sea
is getting worse yet the technician has
yet to return to the super tanker the
AIS systems that automatic
identification systems are now showing
the Adrian Darya one later the
technician had finished his work and
returned to shore but who will end up
with a hundred and forty million dollars
worth of crude oil this is obviously
going to be one of the most tracked
vessels over the next few days and
therefore we're gonna have a very clear
idea where it goes and we can have a
very clear idea of any vessels that come
alongside in order to transit the cargo
last Thursday gibraltars Supreme Court
lifted the detention order on the ship
after assurances from Iran that it would
not deliver its cargo of crude oil to
Syria complying with the European Union
sanctions on that country an attempt by
the United States to reimpose the
detention under its own sanctions was
dismissed by the court on Sunday as a
reflagged renamed ship prepared to leave
Gibraltar announced it couldn't follow
up on a subsequent u.s. district court
warrant that a detention of the ship and
the forfeiture of her cargo it was six
weeks ago the super tanker was captured
off the coast of this tiny British
territory at the tip of the Iberian
Peninsula it's overlooking the African
coastline and it's the Gateway to the
Mediterranean a British frigate docking
here but destined for the Strait of
Hormuz to take over escort duties
serves as a reminder of the tension
there it had escalated with the ongoing
detention of a British flag tanker
Stenner Ampera this is the closing of
one chapter of a crisis and the start of
a new one that's now charting an unknown
course Andrew Symonds al Jazeera off the
coast of Gibraltar